so can I just say I wish I had a show
like this when I was growing up like a
million years ago but I always said I
had this show because I didn't have
anyone that kind of look like me or or
spoke to any sort of experiences I had
in my family what's the reaction been
like for you guys over the past few
seasons more than I could even ask for
yeah it's been so much more than a show
to so many people that it's just like we
we have to pinch ourselves all the time
that it's us that gets to play these
roles yeah yeah and we're just proud to
be inspiring like the kids who are who
are seeing themselves in our show yeah
yeah that's still cool now a lot of
twists and turns or the first two
seasons what have you been paying
attention at all to like fan theories
about what's what's going on like what
do you like actually what you're like
wait for some reason MA say it's not
going to be with season and at which of
all what does it feel like to get to be
able to work on a show where I mean not
only the it also you guys are getting
along and have a great time where the
fandom is is super involved and you get
to represent for all sorts of people
like wasn't like to be able to have all
of that in one project it's crazy it's
crazy it's it's it's overwhelming
because it's you you want to do it right
you know and I feel like just we've got
the pieces and you know there's all of
us and we have such a good relationship
with each other enough so that we can
put it on each other to help and so it
just creates this this unit we don't
want to let them down yeah and it's like
we're so honored and proud to be able to
tell this story and the fact that it
resonates with so many people and I'm
sure everyone gets personal mess
from people who are actually going
through similar situations and they want
our input right I'm like oh my god you
want my advice
yeah like it so it's amazing I'm not
this young boy at the orthodontist and
[Laughter]
he came up to me and he said hey man I'd
tell you that uh that what you guys are
on that show is really inspiring
you guys have noted me motivated me to
pursue a better life
his family was wasn't the gang life and
all that right and he said I just wanted
to tell you that I'm going to college
now and you know pursuit of a better
life and I left the gang life and uh
just he pretty much said thank you and
just walked away we look at the pages
when you get the script I'm assuming
like you're reading them on your own
you're calling each other been like oh
yeah season two they're always at each
other's houses
a little different how did you find
yourselves like laughing out loud or
shocked that what you're reading I mean
these writers are so well at writing the
unexpected yeah and like every time
you're like oh my god I can't wait for
this to happen you're like wait and what
happen
I sometimes I'm like these writers are
like how intelligent are you like that
I'd be like and then they woke up from a
dream I feel like they're really trying
to challenge us to as individuals as
actors like before we started season two
or was it three they like brought us
into the room and like gave us
specifically what notes they're gonna
bring to us for the scripts and how
they're gonna challenge us so that was
really cool that's cool awesome I'm
thoroughly enjoying the show guys
anything thank you so much for your time
everything thank you